shift one
we must move care away from hospitals
and closer to the community
the NHS must become a Neighborhood
Health Service shift to we must move
from a mindset that views Health as all
about sickness to one where we put
prevention first right across Society
so we'll take bold action where early
intervention can make a huge difference
on Mental Health
and make no mistake we intend to
revolutionize mental health treatment in
this country
8 500 new mental health professionals
specialist access in every school
guaranteed treatment inside four weeks
for anyone who needs it
and look the mission we're launching
today isn't just an NHS mission
it's a Health Mission
when we talk about a new deal for
working people on employment rights
about good work for all that's a health
policy
when we say We'll provide breakfast
clubs with healthy food for all primary
school children that's a health policy
when we commit to restoring a decent
home standard to regulating the water
industry to a new Clean Air Act they're
all Health policies
and when I say we will take on the
social media companies who push
dangerous misogyny on our children
I am saying very clearly to those who
profit from harming our children no
not in Britain
and today we go further on that
we will change advertising rules and we
will make sure that products which are
harmful to our children's health vaping
junk food sugary snacks cannot be
advertised to our children no
not in Britain shift three technology a
revolution that will accelerate the
first two shifts and Herald a different
kind of Health Care
a move from an analog to a digital NHS a
tomorrow service not just a today
service
and mark my word this can be
transformational
the route to the NHS offering shorter
waiting times better treatment early
diagnosis and meaningful prevention
Britain leaves the world in science and
technology we can make this happen this
is the game changer the light at the end
of the tunnel this is what will make the
NHS fit for the future
I'll give an example
33 million people downloaded the NHS app
during the pandemic and it's a good app
but that extraordinary opportunity
it's been wasted
labor would take the app and Innovations
like it
we would deepen them expand them and put
them in the hands of patients
and use them to transform our
relationship with the NHS
get this right and it means moving to a
fully digital patient records never
again handwritten notes getting lost
it means booked appointments appropriate
self-referral rooms remind us to get
checkups and screening the latest
guidance on treatment
patients in control of their own data
choosing how it's used and how it's
shared
this will get rid of a divide between
those confident to speak up for
themselves
and those who can't
and look if we make sure everyone is
supported then we can take people on
this journey and it will mean people can
get better choices we'll get faster care
can manage their own health
in truth it's about politicians catching
up with the public and the NHS catching
up with the revolution that's already
happened in the rest of our lives
and it doesn't stop there
technology provides more choice and
Powerful patients
but it also saves lives
take artificial intelligence
AI will change the nature of Health Care
and Britain is good at AI
I'll give an example
lung cancer is the number one cause of
cancer-related deaths in the UK
274 000 patients waiting for 11 days or
more to hear back from the scan
which could tell them if they have
cancer
AI can reduce workload and raise
productivity but here's the real thing
when used properly by a radiologist
it can reduce missed lung cancer
diagnosis by 60 percent
and because it's quicker because it's
more accurate the lives it could save
through early diagnosis are countless
but to make this happen innovators need
one route into the NHS not many
incentives to innovate throughout the
system
fewer barriers to adoption fewer hurdles
to clear less bureaucracy more clinical
trials and a government that uses its
full power to back our world-leading
life sciences